MARTIN OMANDER: Welcome to
the "Root Access" show.
My name is Martin Omander, and
I work in Google Developer
Relations with Startup
Outreach.
In this show, we will discuss
common issues and problems
that startups have.
And in this first episode, we'll
discuss getting a seed
round of funding.
My guest today is Don Dodge,
also from Developer Relations.
Don, would you tell us what
you do at Google?
DON DODGE: Yes.
I'm a Developer Advocate
at Google.
I work with startups and help
them be successful using
Google technologies
to build their
applications and their companies.
There are about 200 of us that
do that, and I've been doing
it for about three years.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
Don, I hear a lot of terms about
funding of startups--
angel round, seed rounds,
series A, series B.
What do they mean?
Could you lay them out for us in
the lifecycle of a startup?
DON DODGE: Sure.
There's several levels.
The first one is usually called
Friends and Family.
And it's called Friends and
Family because that's where
you get the money.
And it's typically $50,000,
maybe $100,000, that you would
get from your friends
or family members.
And at that stage, you really
don't have a company.
You have an idea that you want
to pursue, and maybe build
into a company.
So after that stage, you get
to the Seed Round, which is
typically funded by angels.
So it's sometimes called
Seed Round, sometimes
called Angel Round.
That round is typically between
$100,000 and maybe all
the way up to $800,000
or $1 million.
Angels are executives from big
tech companies that have made
a lot of money.
More typically, they're founders
of startups that have
sold their company and made a
lot of money, and are looking
to invest in young entrepreneurs
and new ideas
and new companies.
The next level up after the
Angel Round or Seed Round is
the Series A. And it's called
Series A because that's the
first series of equity
capital.
So it goes A, B, C, D in
the different rounds.
Those are funded by venture
capitalists or VCs.
And those rounds tend to be more
like $1 to $2 million of
capital raised, and it's for
equity in the company.
So they're actually taking
stock in the company.
Whereas those previous rounds,
the Friends and Family or the
Angels, those tend to be what
are called convertible notes.
And they're called convertible
because they convert from a
note into the Series A equity
stock when that happens.
So they're quite different,
and that's the normal
progression.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
So let's focus on
the Seed Round.
When a company gets to that
point, when they're starting
to look for seed capital,
have the founders quit
their day jobs yet?
Where is the company
at that point?
DON DODGE: Yeah.
At the Friends and Family stage,
they probably haven't
quit their jobs yet.
They're still working nights
and weekends to try to make
this happen.
By the time you get to the Seed
Round or Angel Round, one
or two of them have quit their
jobs, and now they're focusing
full time on developing
this idea.
But they don't have much
in the way of a team
or a product yet.
So they might have one or two
founders, or one founder and a
contract coder or something
like that to do something.
They have an idea.
And hopefully, they have
something like a demo, or
something that you can look at
to understand what it is
they're going to build.
It's getting progressively more
and more difficult to
raise the money, and
the bar is raising.
So you have to have, maybe, not
just a prototype, but a
working product with
some beta users
already to get that money.
MARTIN OMANDER: So let's talk a
little bit more about that.
If you have a startup, and
you've gone through the
Friends and Family round.
So you have your demo--
you're thinking it's time
for the Seed Round.
What is the checklist of things
you should have before
you go out and talk to angels?
DON DODGE: Well, you want to
be as far along as you can.
And you want to take it as far
as you can before you raise
that first money.
Because the longer you wait, the
more that you have done,
the easier it is to raise money,
and the more money that
you can raise at a
higher valuation.
That said, when angel investors
are looking at a
company, they want to see two
founders that are committed to
making it happen.
They want to see a business plan
that sort of explains the
idea and where it could go.
So the investor wants to be able
to connect the dots from
where you are now to where
you'll be to have revenue and
maybe have 10,000 customers
or hundreds of
thousands in revenue.
So you don't have to have the
revenue or the customers, but
you need to have a plan
on how to get there.
And in most social or
easy applications,
they want to see users.
So they'd like to see the
product, not in it's complete
state, but at least enough so
that you have some users that
are giving you feedback and what
they call social proof,
where, in a social application,
you have enough
users that you can say, OK,
I can understand how
people will use this.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
So these private individuals,
rather than companies,
investing at this point,
what kind of companies
do they invest in?
What are they looking for?
DON DODGE: Well, angel investors
invest in people
they know, or businesses
that they understand.
So a lot of these investors
are from startups that
successfully sold their
companies, or they're from big
tech companies where they
made a lot of money.
So they tend to understand
software, technical, web,
social, maybe video or mobile
or that kind of thing.
Investors will tend to invest
where they understand the
business, where they have
some experience, where
they can add value.
So they know people in the
industry that can help, or
they know companies that you
need to work with, or they
have experience in building the
companies, so they can add
value and help you build
your company.
So angels tend to look for
those opportunities.
Or the flip side of that
is, they invest
in people they know.
So people that they've worked
with in the past, people who
have worked at startups
that they know.
So those are the two things.
They invest in people they know
or businesses that they
understand.
MARTIN OMANDER: I see.
Do you invest in startups?
DON DODGE: I do, yeah.
I've been doing it for
quite a while.
I'm in 25 companies now.
I just invested in the last
one just last week.
And I tend to invest in
companies that are doing
mobile, social, location, indoor
kinds of things, some
e-commerce.
So it's areas that I've worked
in in the past, and sort of
businesses that I understand.
And I think that's
pretty typical
of most angel investors.
MARTIN OMANDER: How do startups
get in front of the
right angel investors?
It sounds like not any angel
is a fit for every startup.
DON DODGE: That's right.
Well, it usually comes from a
couple of different sources.
One is the angel investor
already knows that person
because they worked with them at
a previous company, or they
are introduced to them
by trusted advisers.
So someone who knows the startup
and knows the angel
investor will put them together
and introduce them.
Those are the two
typical ways.
VCs can also sort of introduce
you to people, where they're
not ready to put their money
in, but they'll introduce
founders to angel investors
who will put up the money.
So there's a variety
of different ways.
But basically, it's either you
have to know the angel
investor already, have worked
with them in the past, or they
got introduced by someone
that they trust.
MARTIN OMANDER: What is a
startup to do, a startup
founder, if they don't
know angel investors?
DON DODGE: I think the best way
to do it is go to other
startup founders
that you know.
So typically, you're going to
know someone who was in a
startup or a founder at another
startup, and ask them
to introduce you to investors.
Or you're going to know
investors who have invested in
other things and ask them
for introductions.
So it's really just reaching out
to your network of friends
and coworkers, and seeing if
they know investors and
getting an introduction
that way.
The other way is show
up at conferences.
So conferences like the Launch
Conference or Demo or
TechCrunch Disrupt or Google
I/O, or any of these shows
that are tech conferences,
typically there are a lot of
investors there.
And if you go to these
conferences, you're going to
meet people and meet investors
and that's a good way.
The third way is you should be
writing a blog and writing
about your experiences, and
people will find you that way.
So one of those three ways,
you can find an investor.
MARTIN OMANDER: I see.
So tell us a little bit more
about this convertible note.
What does a deal typically
look like?
What are typical numbers
involved in the Seed Round?
DON DODGE: So a convertible
note in a Seed Round is
usually somewhere between
$100,000 and maybe up to $1
million that you're raising.
A convertible note typically has
an interest rate, like say
2% to 4% interest, and it has
a discount to the equity.
They call it a convertible note,
because it converts from
debt to equity at
the Series A.
So it might say 2% to 4%
interest rate, a 20% discount.
What that means is, if you raise
your Series A at a $5
million valuation, the seed or
angel investor gets a 20%
discount to that.
So a 20% discount off of $5
million is $4 million.
So you get to put your money
in at $4 million, while the
series A investor puts theirs
in at $5 million.
So those are the basic terms.
There's also a cap sometimes.
A cap means if I put in my money
early, and you raise a
Series A at a $20 million
valuation, that's not really
fair to the investors.
So what they'll say is there'll
be a 20% discount to
the Series A price or a cap
of, let's say, $4 million.
So it doesn't matter if you
raise your Series A at $10
million, the angel investor's
going to get in
at a cap of $4 million.
So the three basic terms are
the interest rate, the
discount to the next round, and
the cap on the valuation.
MARTIN OMANDER: It's going to be
hard to know what valuation
it will be one round
into the future.
DON DODGE: That's precisely why
they do convertible notes.
In the past, they used to try to
do Series A, where you have
to establish the valuation
that you're going to
put the money in.
But the reality is that it's so
early that you don't know
what the valuation's
going to be.
So a convertible note allows the
investor to put money into
the company, and have a floor
and a ceiling on what the
valuation will be.
So that 20% discount gives them
a discount off whatever
that valuation is established
by the VCs later.
The cap also protects them
from the upside.
So the valuation can go to $10
million or $20 million, but at
least the early seed-stage
investor gets their valuation
capped at an amount like, say,
$4 million or $5 million.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
What should startups look for?
Or rather, should startups
look for anything in an
investor except money?
And if so, what?
DON DODGE: Yeah.
You want people who
can help you.
So VCs always say that they do
more than write a check.
They help you build
a business.
And you want to do the same
thing with angel investors.
So you want to look for angels
who have maybe had experience
in this market segment before,
or have built a company
before, or know people in the
industry or companies in the
industry that you want
to partner with.
So you want to look for angel
investors who have experience,
who have connections, who can
help you, give you advice on
when to do certain things or
how to avoid mistakes.
So these angel investors--
they call them angels because
they help you.
They're like angels who descend,
and fix things for
you and help you.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
OK.
So you see startups coming and
asking for seed investments.
What are some of the common
mistakes you see startups make
when they're looking for
seed investment?
DON DODGE: Well, there's a
couple mistakes, common ones.
First one is, they don't
raise enough money.
So they have fairly modest
goals, and they might raise
$100,000 when they really
need $500,000.
And raising money takes
a lot of time.
It's distracting.
It takes you away from building
the product, and
building the company that
you want to build.
So I think the first mistake
is they don't
raise enough money.
So always try to raise twice
as much as you think you're
going to need, because you're
probably estimating wrong.
And if you have more money
than you need,
then life is good.
So don't worry about it.
So that's the first mistake--
not raising enough money.
Second mistake is taking
money from people
who can't help you.
Then you're not getting the
value out of that investment
if they're not experienced
people who have built a
company before, or who can make
connections for you that
you need, introduce
you to people.
And actually, looking ahead to
raising that venture capital
round, you want your angel
investors to be the people who
can help open the door so that
you can raise your venture
capital round.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
So how do you think about what
is enough for the Seed Round?
You said it's a common mistake
to ask for not enough.
How do you determine
what is enough?
DON DODGE: Well, I think the
real question is what are you
going to do with this money?
So what milestone are
you going to reach?
And I think that means
that you have to
have the product working.
You have to have users, or you
have to have first revenue.
So you need to think of how long
is it going to take me to
build this product?
How long is it going to
take me to get to the
first 10,000 users?
How long is it going to take me
to get to the first million
dollars of revenue?
And sort of map that out.
And there's no correct answer,
because you don't really know.
But estimate how long it's
going to take you.
Figure out how much money you're
going to burn between
now and then, and then
double it, because
you're probably wrong.
So that's how I do it.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
Multiply it by pi?
DON DODGE: Well, you could.
MARTIN OMANDER: Two is--
two is enough.
Don, are you seeing any
trends or changes?
Is angel investing different
now than it was a
couple of years ago?
DON DODGE: I think there are
more angels involved now.
AngelList has been a boon
to the industry.
AngelList is a place where
angel investors can view
business plans and proposals
from hundreds and hundreds of
entrepreneurs and startups.
So I think there are more
angels involved.
There's more money available.
But the angels are getting
smarter and
demanding more progress.
They're demanding that the teams
be more fully developed,
that the product be out there
at least in beta, or have
users that are using it that
sort of prove that, yes, this
team can deliver.
Yes, there are users
who are interested
in using the product.
So I think it's getting
a little harder.
Even though there are more
angels involved, and there's
more money available, it's
raised the bar on the quality
and how far you have to be
before they write a check.
MARTIN OMANDER: Is that
a good thing?
DON DODGE: Well, some would
argue that there are too many
companies being funded.
And they talk about the Series
A crunch, where lots and lots
of companies get angel funding,
but then can't raise
the Series A. So some would
argue that there's too much
angel funding.
And I don't believe
that's true.
I think that the more people out
there trying their ideas
and building their companies,
the better off we all are.
And yeah, not all of them are
going to raise a Series A. But
that happens all the way up the
chain, where you raise a
Series A, and they have
struggled to raise a series B.
MARTIN OMANDER: I've been in
a startup like that, yes.
DON DODGE: Yeah, it happens.
So no, I don't think
there's too many.
I think more angel investors
getting involved and more
startups springing up result in
more opportunities for big
companies to emerge.
So I think it's a good thing.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
Finally, Don, if viewers only
remember one or two things
about the seed investment
round, what is the most
important for startups
to remember?
DON DODGE: Well, when investors
look at a company or
look at an opportunity, they're
thinking about team,
number one.
So don't go it alone.
You have to have at least
one other co-founder.
And it's all about the team.
So have a strong team of people
who you have a lot of
confidence in, where you have
complimentary skills, where
they cover things that you
don't, where you have
confidence that you
can build this.
So team is number one.
The second is make sure you
raise enough money.
Don't get caught short.
And maybe the third thing is
have a good idea of how you're
going to produce revenue.
The days are over when you could
say, we're just going to
focus on the product and build
audience, and figure out how
to monetize later.
Those days are over.
Now you have to have a plan on
how you're going to get from
where you are today to revenue
so that an investor can
connect the dots from where
you are to where
they want to be.
MARTIN OMANDER: I've been
in one or two startups
that were like that.
Let's figure out how to
make money later.
Doesn't always work out.
Thank you, Don, for sharing
your experience with us.
DON DODGE: Well, thanks
for having me.
MARTIN OMANDER: So thank
you for listening.
In the next episode, we'll
talk about how you, as a
startup, can get the
attention of A
list influential bloggers.
Please look at the programs
listings for "Root Access" on
GDL and see you next time.
Bye.